ce guillaume chevrollier pour le groupe
l'est républicain merci même la
présidente mes chers collègues monsieur
le premier ministre
l'état islamique des chèques
l'organisation terroriste les plus
riches de l'histoire les extorsions de
fonds et les activités crapuleuses sont
la principale ressource de
l'organisation devant le pétrole et le
gaz
son patrimoine est évalué à plus de 2000
milliards d'euros et son budget 2015 à
2,6 milliards d'euros
monsieur le premier ministre pour lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme
il faut s'attaquer à son financement
bercy vient d'annoncer une pluie de
mesures à prendre tant au niveau
français qu'européen visant à renforcer
le pouvoir des autorités financières et
notamment de trac fin concrètement il
s'agit de mieux contrôler les transferts
physique de capitaux aux frontières
actuellement l'obligation déclarative ne
s'appliquerait ni aux transferts de
capitaux par fret et voie postale ni aux
valeurs telles que l'or et les pierres
précieuses
par ailleurs il faut faire reculer
l'anonymat dans l' usage des cartes
prépayées quant aux avoirs des
terroristes seuls leurs comptes
bancaires peuvent être gelée aujourd'hui
il faut donc impérativement étendre ce
gel aux biens immobiliers mobiliers aux
voitures ainsi qu'aux prestations
sociales
si toutes ces mesures vont dans le bon
sens nous demandons que les paroles se
transforment en actes
il n'y a plus de temps à perdre les
français sont inquiets
monsieur le premier ministre quel est le
calendrier d'application de ce plan qui
fait suite à des annonces qui ont été
déjà fait en mars dernier par ailleurs
nous savons tous qu une lutte efficace
ne peut se faire que dans un cadre
international a minima européens où en
sont les négociations avec nos
partenaires
la france est elle en capacité
d'entraîner l'europe dans ce combat
contre le financement du terrorisme
merci monsieur le député la barre l'état
monsieur le ministre des finances mais
il ya encore une question de lui d iran
contrairement à ce qui est écrit merci
beaucoup à la main
présidente monsieur le député merci
d'avoir souligné à la fois les décisions
qui ont été annoncées en février dernier
j'y reviendrai en quelques mots et les
décisions non pas que bercy mais que le
ministre que je suis a annoncé il y a
quelques jours pour mieux lutter vous
avez raison de le souligner contre le
financement du terrorisme
je le redis ici lutter contre le
terrorisme c'est lutter y compris en
intervenant à l'extérieur massivement
comme la france le fait déjà depuis
plusieurs mois et elle a encore renforcé
son potentiel de frappe mais c'est aussi
lutter contre le financement du
terrorisme lui-même
j'avais annoncé qu' il fallait à baisser
le niveau de possibilités de paiement en
espèces c'est fait j'avais annoncé qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait un signalement
systématique à trac fin des dépôts et
des retraits d'espèces supérieure à dix
mille euros c'est fait j'avais annoncé
qu'il fallait a baissé de 8000 euros à
1000 euros le seuil à partir duquel le
changeurs manuels doivent vérifier
l'identité du client
c'est fait je pourrai ainsi me suis fait
toute une série de décisions annoncées
en février qui sont aujourd'hui en
action et heureusement parce que
plusieurs de ces mesures ont permis soin
d'éviter des attentats en déjouant ceux
qui voulaient les mener à bien
soit pour les derniers événements
dramatiques que nous avons connus
d'identifier un certain nombre de
personnes qui étaient dans l'entourage
de ces terroristes et d'agir en
conséquence
mais vous avez parfaitement raison aussi
de dire monsieur le député nous pouvons
le reconnaître tous ensemble qu'il faut
aussi agir au niveau européen il ya une
directive qui a été adoptée en juin
dernier en juin 2015
à la demande de la france on appelle ça
la 4e directives de lutte contre le
blanchiment et contre le financement du
terrorisme
nous avons commencé à la mettre en
oeuvre avec des dispositions qui ont
déjà été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale
l'ensemble de nos partenaires doivent le
faire avant le 1er janvier 2017 je pense
que c'est trop loin et donc je
demanderai le 8 décembre prochain à ce
que tous les pays des 28 pays de l'union
européenne dont la france mais en
beaucoup plus rapidement ces mesures
indispensables à une lutte efficace
contre le financement du terrorisme
la parole est un monsieur francs